[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt's eine eistorte mit
frischen beeren sehr lecker super
einfach in der herstellung denn ich
glaube ich brauche jetzt echt nur zehn
minuten zubereitungszeit und den rest
erledigt dann der gefäße ich wollte fast
backofen sagen aber nein bleibt der
backofen kalt für die grundmuster nehme
ich etwas quark butter zucker vanille
extrakt und sahne und habt ihr meine
vier früchte ich nehme blaubeeren
himbeeren brombeeren und erdbeeren und
keine eisbären okay er macht sie sind so
gebraucht einfach nur ein mixer oder
einem stabmixer also irgendwie müsse er
halt die früchte zerkleinern
deswegen werde ich jetzt alles im mixer
zu bereiten das heißt auch erstmal die
ice grundmasse ich gebe jetzt denkt
gewagter rein dann kommt hier
puderzucker dazu extrakt
da kommt die sahne dazu und das ist bei
mir immer so ein bisschen flockig und
der musik das ist logisch aus denn es
hat seine bio sahne und das setzten sich
eben daran ganz gerne mal oben ab ist
nicht schlimm
jetzt einfach kurz durch mixa ihr seht
schon ihr müsst keine sahne steif
schlagen
jetzt nehme ich mir hier viel besser und
für sie gleichmäßig mit der masse das
heißt einfach die masse vierteln ich war
ständig ein schönes bild habe sehr schön
gleichmäßig aufteilen
beim messbecher habe ich jetzt natürlich
den vorteil dass ich es ab messen kann
also ich kann es ablesen wie voll es ist
oder erstellt schälchen auf eine frage
oder ihr lebt nach augenmaß
und jetzt gibt hier einfach eure früchte
rein wenn ihr nur drei stunden dann ist
das eben nur dritteln ich habe jetzt
hier frische erdbeeren bereits vom grün
befreit brombeeren das ist echt sich die
einzige frucht die hier nicht bei mir im
garten wächst also das muss ich noch
ändern
irgendwo muss noch ins straucheln
himbeeren und blaubeeren habe ich auch
im garten aber ich würde sagen dass ich
hier gerne blaubeeren aus dem tk nehme
den glauben wurden irgendwann gezüchtet
das heißt das hier ist die urform die
sind außen blau unten und blau
aber da war einfach das problem wenn man
sie gegessen hat hat man richtig blaue
finger im blauen mund und alles bekommt
und dann haben sie praktisch fettfrei
gezüchtet also diese kulturheidelbeeren
gezüchtet die außen blau sind aber ihnen
nicht das heißt die kann man essen und
bekommt dann keinen blauen mund und
keine blauen finger
die wachsen auch bei unserem garten aber
gerade wenig torten backen und cremes
hersteller nämlich die weil ich einfach
eine richtig tolle farbe bekommen ohne
farbstoffe
das ist wächst die natürliche süße die
natürliche vielfalt diese farbpracht das
natürlich jetzt auch nicht mit den
fingern rein denn dann habe ich bis
heute abend blaue hände und jetzt werde
ich folgendes tun ich werde jetzt hier
einfach nacheinander die creme mit den
früchten pürieren wirklich jede frucht
für sich alleine
damit sich die farben nicht vermischen
ich möchte einfach dass das eis nicht
nur lecker schmeckt sondern toll
aussieht wenn euch die optik egal ist
dann püriert alles miteinander dann
müsst ihr auch keine vier förmchen
füllen und trennen
dann habt ihr einfach eine bunte
fruchtige eismassen
wie fühlt sich das jetzt einfach noch
mal zurück und kann kurz alles
durchprobieren
und wer möchte kann auch gerne den
becher dann kurz ausspülen damit sich
wirklich hier am anfang schon mal nichts
vermischt
[Musik]
ich glaube ich gebe bei den laufwerken
gleich noch ein spritzer zitronensaft
dazu denn jetzt habe ich hier schon
dunkles lila von den brombeeren und die
blaubeeren die werden so leicht pink
wenn man so ein bisschen zitronensaft
dazu gibt da nämlich eine andere farbe
erzeugen
sprichst 1 nicht aus
ja das ist mir so ähnlich da gebe ich
noch ein bisschen
[Musik]
gleich ganz anders das war ein live act
und noch ein live-act wenn ihr jetzt
blaue finger habt von den blaubeeren
nehmt ihr einfach die ausgedrückte
zitrone
gebt eure finger hier rein und dann sind
sie wieder schönweitz können auch so
allgemein immer wieder machen dann habt
ihr schöne weiße fingernägel von live
aid und den restlichen maschinen als
verschiedenen djs wieder live ich hätte
jetzt zum befüllen auch eine silikonform
so eine längliche aber ich treibe das
machen könnt wenn ihr jetzt nur so einer
glasform zum beispiel habe darauf jetzt
einfach ein bisschen frischhaltefolie
damit später gut raus stürzen lässt
ansonsten wie gesagt könnt ihr wunderbar
eine silikonform nehmen denn dabei kann
das eis wunderbar aus aber so gibt es
auch brot einfach nur darauf achten dass
es schön flach gelegt jetzt könnt ihr
entweder so machen dass ihr die eine
schicht einfüllt einfriert und sobald
ich gefroren ist die nächste darauf
nochmal frieren oder ihr macht einfach
mit so bisschen farbverlauf dass ich so
ein bisschen vermischt so werde ich
machen also stürzt hier nicht rein
ein bisschen
[Musik]
ich glaube es war auch richtig cool
gewesen immer in der mitte griffen und
dann hat man ja wenn wir uns immer in
die mitte gießen und damit das später so
diese wir sind zehn kuchen
[Musik]
eine schüssel hat übrigens ein
fassungsvermögen von etwas mehr als 1600
millilitern
deswegen habe ich hier die menge auch
direkt ausgerechnet passt perfekt rein
mini rest ist noch übrig aber das krieg
ich mir in so einem mini eiswürfel
behälter einfach ein
ich könnte daraus auch mini als
würfelchen machen denn dann habt ihr so
snacks nur so eiswürfel konzert ihr
könnt ja auch machen
also das wird jetzt eingefroren bis es
komplett fest ist und dann überlege ich
mir noch wirklich ein kranz boden mache
oder halt ich vor lauter konfetti im
kopf ich meine natürlich meine natürlich
eis konfekt nicht eislöffel konfetti
eiskonfekt
das eis ist jetzt gefroren und ich nehme
es jetzt hier aus direkt auf eine platte
jetzt echt gespannt wie es schmeckt und
wie es aussieht wenn es nicht gleich
geht einfach warmes wasser drüber
fließen lassen habe ich probier's mal
tritt ohne nein das geht nicht
da muss ich halt sagen sind silikon
formen dankbare aber mit etwas geduld
kriegen wir es auch hier raus denn ich
habe hier beim einfüllen nicht
aufgepasst da ist die freischaltung von
mir einfach runter gerutscht
was ist stehen sondern bis es raus
flutscht aber ich kann euch zeigen wie
toll das eis konfekt hier raus kommt
denn da habe ich ja die eiswürfel
förmchen guckt mal geht das geschmeidig
wunderbar
also bei so sachen feiere ich silikon
dann schon hart da kriegt ja wirklich
das eis perfekt raus ich warte einfach
ganz kurz um zeige euch gleich wie es
ausgelöst aussieht ein bisschen an
getauscht
packe ich das hier rüber
ich habe es mit etwas gewalt
rausgekriegt ich hab einfach und dieses
gitter und das wasser gestellt habe
wasser drauf laufen lassen ein bisschen
geklopft und dann ging ich könnte aber
auch einfach 23 minuten warten und dann
jetzt auch von alleine so ist das eis
eigentlich schon fertig aber ich will
sie es auch dekorieren das heißt ich
lebe jetzt hier noch früchte drauf die
frische bomben habe ich jetzt heute
keine mehr habe ich nehme die gefrorenen
dekoriert es hier so drauf und drunter
und drüber
unternehmen sind bei erdbeben
das ist die muss man sich einfach
anschneiden man sieht dann hübsch sind
so richtig schön wenn sie werden jetzt
auch beim anschnitt runterfallen aber so
für den gesamteindruck finde ich das
schon immer schön einmal anrichten und
dann anschneiden
ich gebe jetzt hier noch weiße schock
weil ich schon drauf die mache ich jetzt
hier aus kuvertüre mit einem sparschäler
es war die perfekte rolle
aber dann fällt die einfach runter ich
glaube er wollte
[Musik]
oh ja ich bin es auch schön wenn es
daneben liegen
ruby drops hirsch wir packen noch ruby
drops drauf das ist jetzt ein eis de
luxe
[Musik]
ag sarah kommt die schokolade passt
ich glaube da ist farbenblind
also du bist wohl in der farbe ja okay
okay vielleicht hätte ich keinen kuchen
messer nehmen sollen sondern ein
richtiges ich dachte es geht geschmeidig
aber sicher gefroren ich habe nur das
problem wenn ich dann warten manchmal
schneider können das problem ist immer
diese deko china jetzt ist ja sehr schön
und richtig schön wenn ich aktiv da drin
und jetzt muss ich eben frucht bombe
überspielt weiter über den spar machen
als mit einem scharfen messer geht sich
halt nur so ein stumpfes kuchen messer
zückt das messer
das ist er für seine torten und trocken
kuchen das ist ein super aussieht falles
riesenstück na bitte da dachte ich könne
mir ich weiß nur nicht wie jetzt müssen
wir so ein bisschen auftauen lassen hier
so ein bisschen
ich habe das gefühl dass 3m pulli hier
nicht noch mal ein messer ich nenne von
mir alles lecker
ich verstand was mich erinnern darf man
morgen ich weiß dass du sagst was da
wohl aber in die sind nehme ich mal an
ein bisserl zu katrin aber trotzdem
nicht so viel zucker wien fruchtzwerge
habe das als kind geliebt war diesen wir
hatten nie diese stile und haben einfach
so türkischer tee oder für wir haben
alle für diese espresso rein und dann oh
gott dieses eis weil es war ja nicht in
jedem buch zwergsterne war immer nur im
sommermonat
und dann hatten die so komische figuren
man muss fairerweise sagen es ist nicht
das cremiges eis aber man hat auch ohne
rühren also normalerweise wenn man ein
cremiges eis haben möchte muss man
vorher neuer sahne milch wasser erwärmen
und cremig rühren und dann entweder als
bereiter eingeben oder halt im
gefrierschrank und dann immer wieder
rühren das ist einfach eine schicht eis
was man eben so einfriert ganz schnell
gemacht ist und man habe eben keine
arbeit ja unschön erfrischen
sehr lecker ich finds auch brot das
heißt wenn es nach machen wollt probiert
gern mal aus das rezept gibt es auch
sallys - blog de oder in meiner app die
saar ankunft sich hier ist noch durchs
eis durch weil sie nicht warten kann
dieses bisschen auftaucht oder antwort
ich habe für mich auch durch da kommen
wir teil des aka magath ich sehe schon
wieder die nächste headline sally taylor
als chakalaka mit ihrer was bin ich
eigentlich was man ja eigentlich schiff
bis zum nächsten mal
background sängerin
[Musik]